could you please tell me your name and
whoops you are
my name is Justine or iJustine as I go
by on Instagram which is how I would
prefer to be addressed in real life so
if we could just do that from now on I'm
an Instagram addict and we're actually
calling me an addict because I feel like
that's a negative connotation to Who I
am like Instagram is art its its beauty
its how people should see the world and
you're making it seem like it's a
negative thing like drugs not good drug
at it not good
Instagram addict not good until we just
seen could you please just calm down a
cobalt it's the name of the show okay
that's whatever we can be Ellen please
okay it's your show not mine so why do
you use Instagram I use Instagram
because I've always wanted to be a
photographer and I don't really have any
photography skills whatsoever so using
Instagram allows me to be the next
Picasso Picasso is a painter oh he's a
painter you know what I meant
attitude sustained I do call me names
face do you feel that there are any
inappropriate times to use Instagram no
I really don't think there's any
inappropriate times to use this to him I
have this one follower right II
Instagram says and once you add a filter
to I swear to you it's it's beautiful oh
it's magnificent baby it's like nothing
you'll ever see okay look or unsee
oh my matter do you feel like that's a
difference between real life and
Instagram yeah there is a difference a
real life sucks a lot now since I
started using Instagram because I'm
seeing things through my real eyes and
my real eyes don't see filters like
Instagram does so I've come up with this
plan a very cheap plan unlike the insta
glasses which you can purchase but now
I'm not all about that you just need to
get some saran wrap some markers and
you're good to go okay this is my fun
little DIY project and if I used
Pinterest I would probably have put this
on there and asked you guys to all pin
it but I don't do that
now some people do not pinch us to stay
let's make sure you leave your mouth
open so you can breathe its most
important
just keep coloring right over top of
your eyes you can use different colors
for blending to get different filters
life is so much out of right now no
again stenography is always full of
people's food how do you feel about
instagrams see it for me food instagrams
or how I eat I don't even eat anymore
I just ghost my Instagram feed and just
hope that one of my friends is gonna
upload a delicious pizza a delicious
sandwich or maybe even a salad if I'm
feeling healthy that day oh this is
great my friend she just instagrammed a
milkshake you see it oh yes I see it it
looks quite good boy I'm sorry what are
you doing here right now no I'm driving
a new phone yeah the thing is you need
to actually believe that you're having a
milkshake
ah you're disgusting do you know how
much so good it's so on your diet now
well I don't watch fry it can you get
out of a studio could get her out of
here don't even invite us today